what's up guys bang bang take a little
uber ride real quick so i figured i'd
quickly talk about something that just
is bugging the hell out of me everyone
keeps saying that bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are used by criminals
and money launders terrorist financing
all these bad actors are all using
bitcoin but actually when you start to
break it down everyone knows the choice
currency of criminals around the world
still us dollars so over two trillion
dollars a year that's laundered in u.s
dollars going through many of the major
banks kyc aml etc and on top of that if
you want untrustable payments
and on top of that if you want
untraceable payments there's nothing
better than using cold hard cash that no
one can see on the internet
now of course bitcoin is not only bad
for criminals it's literally
transactions that are put onto an
immutable public ledger that anyone can
go ahead and look at but we're starting
to get more and more data around what
the actual use for illicit purposes are
and lots of anecdotal evidence as well
there's recent studies that show that
less than half a percent of all bitcoin
transactions are actually used for
illicit purposes so obviously criminals
have figured out we shouldn't use
bitcoin for any sort of bad nefarious
use cases
on top of that if we look at the recent
hack from bitfinex back in 2016 those
funds were just recovered two people
were arrested and 3.6 billion dollars
was recovered by law enforcement that
just goes to show how did they do it
they simply looked on the blockchain
that immutable ledger and they were able
to track the coins and when they moved
they figured out where they were moving
to who controlled those accounts and
then they went it and they actually
arrested those people and so just
another example that bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are really bad for
illicit purposes now again that's not
going to stop the public narrative from
spreading there's going to be plenty of
detractors that continue to say oh bad
people uses but they said the same thing
about the internet about computers about
beepers and every other innovative new
technology that's not a reason to stop
actually pushing it forward or to stop
adopting it it simply just means that
there's product market fit and so if
we'd stopped trying to adopt the
internet or computers or mobile phones
because bad people used it would be
worse off as a society and ultimately i
think that's what's going to happen with
bitcoin people are going to realize that
good and bad people are going to use
this technology but the good outweighs
the bad it's net positive and criminals
around the world money launders
terrorists and other bad people the us
dollar is still their choice currency
doesn't mean that we should encourage
the behavior but it just means that the
public narrative's wrong bitcoin is not
only bad for criminals
it means that law enforcement can do
their job better and ultimately what we
are watching is that the world is going
to recognize bitcoin's the best money
around bitcoin's a global store of value
and it creates safer fairer more
accessible markets for everyone